I've got one for you Brady I know you
love a new type of number today we're
doing practical numbers
you like the sound of that so apparently
this is meant to be a good number to use
when designing weights and measures
so things like
um weights or coins or you know lengths
and things like that 20 is a practical
number and I'll tell you what that means
so the idea is we're going to design a
set of Weights it's based on number 20
and the divisors of 20. devices or
factors if you prefer of 20. so imagine
I've got a weight of 20 units whatever
we're going to call them the next weight
is based on the divisor so it's going to
be 10 because it divides 20. all the
other numbers that divide 25 will be the
next weight and we're going to have what
am I going to have next two
no four then I'm gonna have two and then
I have one because you always have one
don't you there we go so that is 20 and
the divisors of 20. now the idea is I'm
going to try and make every value up to
20. so imagine I'm a merchant I've got a
set of scales I've got this set of
Weights here this is a complete set of
weights and I might want to measure
whatever number up to and including 20.
so just check I can do that okay the
idea is we're going to use each weight
just once only
so we won't need to have two sets oh
wait the idea is I'm not I don't need to
use my weight for twice I should be able
to use one of each so let's do that on
your scales yeah on my scales yeah yeah
so for one I can just use the one
weights that's done for two I use the
two weight that's done for three I would
use the two and the one for four I've
got a four weight so that's done for
five I've got a five weight so that's
done as well and maybe it gets more
interesting is six a five and a one
would make six five and a two for a
seven for eight I can use my five a two
and a one again just to say I don't have
to use four twice I can do it this way
what do I need for nine I haven't got a
nine weight so yeah I've got five plus
four great uh ten I've got a ten weight
good basically I'm just going to do the
same thing again now but I've got a ten
weight so it's ten plus one and then
it's ten plus two and then it's ten plus
two plus one and it's ten plus four ten
plus five sixteen ten plus five plus one
ten plus five plus two ten n plus five
plus two plus one nineteen ten plus five
plus four and then that gets me up to
twenty and I can do every number up to
the number itself and I can actually
keep going until I get to like the sum
of all the weights uh which would add up
to 42 in this example and then I stopped
because I can't go any further because
that's the complete set of Weights uh so
that's kind of nice so it's called a
practical number because the idea is
that you could design a set of Weights
that do that
um the idea was that the old weights and
measures are meant to be kind of
superior this is what they say because
they were based on these kinds of
numbers they were based on 16
like 16 ounces in a pound in the old
days it was 20 shillings to a pound as
in pound sterling money 12 is another
practical number inches in a foot 28 is
a practical number so apparently the old
weight and measures were based on these
kind of numbers because you could design
sets of coins or sets of weights and
then you could use them like this in
this combinations to make any number
that you wanted until you got as big as
you could get so this is what they say
that's why they're called practical
numbers oh because yeah the old way to
messes are far superior much better than
10 and what we use now are decimals and
our metrics
thing is I tried to find a set of
Weights that actually do this
or set of coins
they think it exists I don't think this
was actually done I just think this is
mathematicians again these numbers are
far superior I don't think this was
actually ever used it with one exception
which is 16 ounces in a in a pound which
is these weights this is the 16 this is
the eight this is the four this is the
two and this is the one although I think
this is more based on Powers of two
rather than being 16 is a practical
number this is basically binary so if
I'm using different combinations of
powers of two that is what a binary
number is that I found but I didn't find
any
like four gram weights I didn't find any
four Pence coins or four cent coins and
that's where it falls down and so I've
seen sets are nearly like this but but
they don't do it because they don't have
the full thing so let me show you the
sequence of practical numbers let me
show you what they are uh one is a
practical number two is a practical
number four
6 8 12 16 18 20 24 28 some in between
100 it's worth mentioning is a practical
number and so on so these are the
practical numbers here they're not rare
are they they're not completely rare and
we do know how many there are I will
tell you about that but I think it's
worth looking at a set that failed or a
number that fails uh to be practical to
see why it isn't practical so we've got
all these practical numbers so what's
wrong with the ones in between okay
let's take a look at what doesn't work
so if I had a set of weights with 14 14
right divisors are fourteen seven two
and one what can I make I can make one
good I can make two I can make three as
two plus one and then I'm stuck I can't
make four
because I haven't got four weights to
use and I can't add up to four either
the problem is you need to be able to
reach the next divisor that's that's
real that's the Crux of it you have to
be able to get to the next divisor like
stepping stones you need to reach the
next one and then that should get you to
the next one that's the idea so yeah
four I can't make because seven
you know five I can't make six I can't
make because I can't get to Seven I've
got this big gap then seven I can make
because I've got a seven then I can do
seven and one for eight seven and two
and then I'm stuck again 11 and 12 I'm
stuck 13 I'm stuck and I've got a 14
like that so yes you get these gaps the
devices have to be fairly close together
okay that's it the device are they
impractical numbers those ones or we can
call them in Practical numbers they're
not called that but they are now thanks
Brady uh so yeah the devices have to be
fairly close together so practical
numbers tend to be
um powers are two
they tend to be perfect numbers let's
have nice devices that add up to make
the number itself and they tend to be
factorials
because that's you know divisible by one
two three four five six see you can get
away with that uh Prime Orioles that's
when you multiply the primes to get the
consecutive Primes so if I do two times
three or two times three times five or
three two times three times five times
seven those are primordials so again
those are have the devices fairly close
together
and um highly composite numbers which
Brady knows as uh uh anti-prime
anti-primes which if you go to Wikipedia
now it says highly composite numbers
also known as anti-primes no that's just
Brady that doesn't count just Brady yes
Brady
all right again these are numbers though
where the divisors are close together a
nice um test for a practical number
though is you can just test the prime
devices so if you've got a practical
number and it's divisible by a prime P
if you can make p minus one that's for
all your possible Prime devices if you
can make p minus one you can do all the
numbers it's a practical number so
there's a nice little test for it so you
don't have to test every number that
will get you your stepping stones that
will get you from one divisor to the
other that's what you need how many
practical numbers are how many practical
numbers are there I would have thought
they're infinite so yeah there are there
are infinite practical numbers
um in fact a practical number multiplied
by practical number is a practical
number
um also a practical number multiplied by
divisor
is a practical number it does show you
an example of what I'm talking about
I've got say six is a practical number
and I've got two as a practical number
so yeah 2 times 6 is 12 and 12 is a
practical number but I could also do six
times three where three is not a
practical number but it is a divisor of
six and that gets me eighteen and that
is a practical number it is on my list
so you can make practical numbers from
practical numbers so hopefully you can
quickly see that you're going to have
infinitely many practical numbers
including the powers of two so yes you
do have infinitely many of them but we
also know how they're related to the
primes as well so there's a whole bunch
of things that you can do for primes
that haven't been solved that you can
solve for practical numbers and there's
a um a twin practical number result so
twin primes means you've got two prime
numbers that are two apart the
conjecture is there's infinitely many of
them that hasn't been proven well for
practical numbers it has been proven
practical numbers that are two apart
there are infinitely many pairs of those
so tick yes that's been proven goldback
conjecture which says every even integer
greater than two is the sum of two
primes not proven
yeah that is proven with uh practical
numbers so every even numbers the sum of
two practical numbers that's nice
um prime number theorem which is a
proven thing so we know how many primes
there are number of primes less than x
is approximately x divided by the
natural log of x is a famous result it's
called the prime number theorem and
there's a result like that for practical
numbers as well I'll show you what that
looks like let's call it P of X number
of practical numbers less than x and
that is actually quite similar it's X
over log X multiplied by constant I'm
going to call it C for constant and that
constant when we knew that's the case we
knew it was going to be something like
that that was actually calculated
finally by Andrea's
weingartner in 2020 and this is the
value so C this constant is equal to
1.33
607 and stuff what that means is there's
about
more practical numbers than there are
prime numbers so they're kind of rare
yeah
all right yeah I guess they are and they
get more sparse the higher you go yeah
it's just yeah you can see yeah it's
like the um like the prime number yeah
all right yeah at this point I was
telling you that two practical numbers
multiply together makes a practical
number or a practical number multiplied
by divisor makes practical number that
means we can actually minimize this
sequence we can get like the atoms of
practical numbers like the primes of
practical numbers a minimal sequence uh
which is this one two six twenty twenty
eight thirty and so on so all the other
practical numbers can be made out of
this sequence of minimal practical
numbers
so here's a longer list of these atoms
of practical numbers they're also known
as primitive practical numbers it's
sequence
a267124 on the online encyclopedia of
integer sequences if you want to dig
deeper and also on screen you see those
names they're not like the discoverers
of the numbers or anything they're
actually number file patreon supporters
and if you'd like to support numberfile
on patreon there'll be a link on the
screen and in the video description we
appreciate anyone who can help us out
but we also appreciate everyone who
watches the videos so thanks for being
one of them
and we'll be back again soon practically
before you know it with another video
[Music]